a quick reminder to not throw away your  pumpkins once halloween is over because  you can help  feed a pig las vegas livestock has  locations all across the valley to  recycle your old pumpkins and they do it  free of charge  they will become treats to feed pigs and  chickens nearby  they're all being raised not too far  from apex actually the collection  started today it's going to run all the  way through november 6 and you can drop  off those pumpkins 24 hours a day  so we have a list of all the locations a  few of them right here on your screen  there's probably one close to you  or you can always check out our website  at 8newsnow.com